yeah standing question of course is is
Florida prepared for self-government
we'll take that up at some length
tomorrow meanwhile Eric
Edgar's conducted a lot of research with
the Government Accountability in cities
the author of the new book fraud how the
Left plans to steal the next election of
that book was written just before this
last election and actually contains a
section on Brenda Snipes
the very prescient Eric Edgar's joins us
tonight Eric thanks a lot for coming on
so Brenda Snipes is a name that most of
us were not familiar with until very
very recently her position is that she's
being unfairly attacked as a person
MSNBC MSNBC's position she's being
attacked because of her skin color why
do you think she's being attacked well I
think she's not very good at her job
Tucker and I heard the quote earlier
that this is the first time she's been
under attack that would seem to be
another thing that miss knife's is not
very good at counting because
unfortunately her track record is
littered with missteps and violations of
the law I mean in 2018 this election we
know that illegal ballots will count and
the governor's race and in the Senate
race because they were incapable of
cleanly separating illegal ballots from
legal ballots once they'd been opened
from their envelopes so we know that's
going to happen but this is not the
first time she's admitted under oath
that she's allowed illegal immigrants
and felons to cast ballots in Broward
County and violation of numerous laws
you mentioned the time she destroyed the
ballots that seem to have given a boost
to debbie Wasserman Schultz her office
has been found guilty of illegally
opening ballots inappropriately right
and without a proper oversight and so
unfortunately and actually it's a fun
fact when she was challenged on that
topic why is your office opening ballots
outside the presence of the official
canvassing board her argument in court
was well I guess I didn't understand the
meaning of the word canvassing so
unfortunately her history is consistent
with what we're seeing in the present
and it augurs not very good things for
Florida so why wouldn't this be a
concern of the Justice Department I mean
this is a federal election we have a
Voting Rights Act if she's breaking the
law in admitting it why wouldn't the
feds swoop in well you know that's a
great question it's a question a lot of
people have asked and all the the
attention that you know that Broward
County's Racine
right now is how in the world is this
woman still in office now there's a
difference between not being very good
at your job and then violating criminal
statutes and I'm not an attorney but
what I can tell you is is that people I
think have historically been afraid to
challenge Miss Snipes or dr. Snipes
quite honestly because of what you
mentioned they're afraid of being
challenged as and called a racist when
Brenda Snipes is county office Attorney
pushed forward and she was being
criticized because she donated to
political campaigns and actually one of
the county commissioners who was on the
opposing end of one of the campaign's
the Broward County Attorney donated to
the the county the county elections
County Attorney played the race card and
tried to rally support by generating a
bunch of african-american attorneys to
show up in solidarity you know eight of
the nine members of the County
Commission when this issue came up were
Democrats and quite honestly you don't
do very well as the political official
in Broward County if you attack African
American Democrats even though Rick
Scott's a Republican you know he
obviously had statewide aspirations how
well do you think you do statewide in
Florida if you're perceived as a racist
I mean this is how democracy dies isn't
it when you have an openly corrupt
person in charge of counting the votes
admitting in public that she's breaking
the law and no one can do anything about
it I mean why is that not an actual
threat to democracy yeah and I think the
larger threat Tucker to be honest is
she's demonstrated that she's not very
good at counting votes how good do you
think she's been at preventing illegal
votes from actually being cast I mean we
know that there's an effort to
manipulate the selection through illegal
voting there were a hundred and eight
attempts through double votes in
miami-dade in this election which means
people try to cast the second ballot in
the same election the attorneys for Bill
Nelson and Andrew Gilliam have been
criticized because they objected to the
removal or exclusion of known non
citizen votes in Palm Beach County so
you know my concern whatever you want to
say about these 83,000 ballots showed up
after election night what confidence
level do we have about the ballot that
have already been cast well then where
they cast by legal voters
that's exactly right it's it's a R if
you care about democracy and everyone
claims to these are real questions there
thank you very much for that my pleasure
top your book